the war on History ongoing for years now
has two phases the first phase is to
demonize all of our culture's historical
heroes turn them into uh Cartoon
villains basically downplay their
successes and virtues while emphasizing
their shortcomings and shortcomings and
if they did not have enough shortcomings
to emphasize then simply invent evil
Deeds that they didn't actually commit
and this is easy enough to do it's not
like they're around to defend themselves
from the slander so you could say
whatever you want about them then tear
down their statues take their names off
of buildings turn them into sources of
national shame whereas before they were
sources of national pride the left has a
word actually for this first phase it's
problematized which is to make a problem
out of something or someone that was not
a problem before
now it's safe to say at this point that
phase one the problematization phase is
complete
that moves us to phase two
with the old Heroes smoldering on the
historical ashy their monuments all
knocked over and decaying like the
Statue of Liberty and the Planet of the
Apes the next step is to replace them
with new Heroes and where the old Heroes
were great men and women who
accomplished magnificent and
world-changing things yet also being
human-possessed flaws sometimes great
flaws the new Heroes accomplished
nothing worthwhile at all they are
selected not because of their
achievements but because of their
usefulness their utility
to the leftist cultural narrative
obviously the George Floyd murals and
statues are the prime example of this
and also this
Indiana University proudly announces on
their website today quote a new bronze
sculpture memorializing Alfred C
Kinsey's significant and enduring
contributions to Indiana University now
sits on the Bloomington campus marking
the 75th anniversary of The Institute
that bears his name Kinsey
revolutionized the scientific study of
sexual behavior and provoked an
international conversation about
sexuality he founded the Kinsey
Institute the world's leading sexuality
Research Institute in 1947. the
life-size bronze is the work of Melanie
Cooper Pennington a lecturer in the
sculpture in sculpture in the IU School
of art and architecture and design the
sculpture's installation of the
Bloomington campus demonstrates the
University's pride in the living Legacy
of research and academic freedom Kinsey
helped to forge and the institute's
ongoing commitment to equity regarding
sexual diversity established by Kinsey's
research
Equity regarding sexual diversity well
that's one way to put it the other way
to put it is that Alfred Kinsey was a
deviant lunatic and a pedophile who
enjoyed
um researching quote unquote the orgasms
of children and babies
the notorious table 34 from the book
sexual behavior in the human male
documents the number of orgasms
allegedly experienced by children from
the ages of 15 down to five months old
and he acquired this information by
working with rapists who would abuse
children keep a journal about the
experience and then report back to
Kinsey so in other words he enlisted
pedophiles to rape kids so that he could
get the data he wanted and why did he
want this data well because he wished to
prove that children are sexual beings
from birth
and that all forms of sexual activity
literally all forms including pedophilia
bestiality all of it are legitimate now
you can learn more about this in my film
what is a woman and where we discuss uh
in in more length Alfred Kinsey and also
John money
but this is the man that Indiana
University honors with his own statute
he was the most prolific groomer of the
20th century
there's a reason that the left still
celebrates him today but of course
calling them groomers is is hate speech
I mean they're making statues to Alfred
Kinsey but calling them groomers as hate
speech
yet it's not just child raping
Psychopaths who were being told to honor
this week they're also uh slave Traders
we mustn't forget about them
well only certain historical slave
Traders are worthy of our admiration
specifically the ones whose story is
being told in a major Hollywood film
which is set to Premiere this coming
Friday the movie is called the woman
King
and the absurdity of the title The Woman
King is really the least of its problem
so we don't even have time to talk about
that the official description on Rotten
Tomatoes tells us this
the woman King is the remarkable story
of the agoji the all-female unit of
Warriors who protected the alpha the
African Kingdom of Dahomey in the 1800s
with skills and a fierceness unlike
anything the world has ever seen
inspired by true events the woman King
follows the emotionally epic journey of
General nanosika as she trains the next
generation of recruits and readies them
for battle against an enemy determined
to destroy their way of life
we'll have a little bit more on their
way of life and what exactly that way of
life was in just a second but here's a
little bit of the trailer watch
coming
that threatens Our Kingdom
our freedom
but we have a weapon
they are not beard for
[Applause]
[Music]
my king the Europeans wish to conquer us
they will not stop into the whole of
Africa is passed
we must fight back
to our people
you're asking me to take them
[Applause]
some things are worth fighting for
I offer you a choice fight
or we die
now to be clear this film is about as
historically accurate as like the Power
Rangers but we'll get back to that in a
second it's of course a foregone
conclusion that this movie will be
critically acclaimed it has to be I mean
it's essentially a matter of law or
might as well be at this point that a
story about female African Warriors
killing Europeans
must be praised in the most rapturous
terms possible any critic who dares to
utter a critique or whose Applause is
judged to be lacking in enthusiasm will
be branded or racist than a sexist
and they'll probably throw transphobe
and homophobe in for good measure also
mainstream film critics Who as a group
uh are some of the most pathetic cowards
in all of media which is really really
saying something certainly got the memo
about this reviews of the film were
released on Sunday and the woman King
now boasts a 100 fresh rating on Rotten
Tomatoes if it keeps going at this pace
which it probably will it will go down
as one of the most best reviewed films
of all time
right now it's ahead of like Citizen
Kane and The Godfather in terms of its
of its uh reviews
critics are saying things like the woman
King is a sturdy rousing piece of Studio
entertainment that makes both the new
feel old and the old feel new then also
thrilling and enrapturing emotionally
beautiful and spiritually buoyant the
woman King isn't just an uplifting
Battle Cry it's the movie that director
Prince by the wood has been building
toward her entire career
and then
Fierce Furious and feminine an action
picture that isn't so much released as
Unleashed
talk about a movie of its moment
and other critic adds that the movie is
so spectacular so perfect so wonderful
so miraculous and beautiful he's
planning to jump out of a window as soon
as he submits his review having decided
that his life has reached its Pinnacle
and there's no point of living anymore
it's all downhill from here another one
said that watching the movie was more
glorious than seeing the birth of his
own children
and in fact after the watching the movie
he wishes that his children had not been
born because they're white
now admittedly I made up the last two
reviews but they're not very far from
what the critics are actually saying
all of this
in spite of the fact that the kingdom of
tahomey who are the heroes of this movie
were ruthless killers and slave traders
who conquered and murdered in pursuit of
slaves which were then used as labor
within the kingdom or sold to buyers
outside of the Kingdom
as the Encyclopedia Britannica notes
um before they edit this passage which
I'm sure they will uh the kingdom was
was not it's not just that they had
slaves the kingdom was fundamentally
organized around war and slavery that's
what the whole thing was about uh quote
de homie was organized for war not only
to expand its boundaries but also to
take captives as slaves slaves were
either sold to the Europeans in exchange
for weapons or kept to work the Royal
plantations that supplied food for the
Army in court from approximately 1680 a
regular census of population was taken
as a basis for military conscription
female soldiers called Amazons but the
Europeans served as Royal bodyguards
when not in combat
so
the transatlantic slave trade
could only exist because it was
furnished by the homie along with other
tribes and kingdoms
this is one of the little-known
inconvenient facts about African slavery
we've talked about before on the show it
was a system supported encouraged
promoted facilitated by Africans
themselves
now in the homies case I should be fair
I guess and admit that they didn't
always sell their captives into slavery
sometimes they would um
instead of selling them butcher them in
human sacrifice rituals
human sacrifices were killed for various
rituals to honor Kings and then also uh
there were other forms of human
sacrifices like the concubines of a king
would be killed and buried with him when
he died those sorts of things now
naturally
all indications are this movie does not
really grapple with any of these
unfortunate historical realities on the
contrary they paint the female warriors
of tahomey as as uh as Freedom Fighters
according to one review I read they do
acknowledge that the kingdom had slaves
but they pretend that the woman warriors
were abolitionists that they were
pushing for the end of the slave trade
which is pure fiction of course
actually not only is it fiction
but the slave trade only ended
in the Kingdom of Dahomey because
British blockades forced it to end
here's another inconvenient fact
Europeans abolished the slave trade
above the objections of many African and
Middle Eastern Nations
so Europeans said you're not doing this
none of us are doing slave trade anymore
it's done
while many African and Middle Eastern
Nations said no we want to keep doing
the slave thing because it's it's
profitable to us
now as for the woman Warriors of the
homie they were easily crushed in their
first military engagement with the
French and that's was the end of that
story
now look there's nothing on the surface
wrong with you know making a movie that
fictionalizes historical events
but it is Unthinkable of course that
anything like this could ever be
produced much less receive rave reviews
if the roles were flipped around imagine
a civil war movie where the Confederates
are not only the heroes of the film but
are portrayed as the true abolitionists
you know that's just that movie could
not possibly exist and if it did exist
there would be literal riots in the
street I mean it's not an exaggeration
to say there would be riots the
buildings would be burning if a movie
like that was it came out
any theater that was crazy enough to
play it would be burned to the ground
except
that wouldn't even be on par with this
film because the Confederates were not
nearly as brutal as the kingdom of
dahami was
but this is all a part of our cultural
rewrite of History
you know some men who had slaves were
bad no matter what else they did
Thomas Jefferson George Washington no
matter what else they did
even as the founders of uh our country
they had slaves so we got to tear down
their statues they were scumbags that's
it
while other people who organize their
whole societies around the capture sale
and ritualistic murder of slaves were
good
and deserving of Their Own
hagiographical films
so once again our culture designates new
Heroes for us
and those new Heroes might be criminals
drug addicts child rapists
even slave Traders
not much to admire there but we're told
to
admire them all the same well before you
go uh hit the Subscribe button and ring
the bell and while you're at it if you
want to go watch or listen to my full
show head to dailywire.com And subscribe
you can also catch my show on Spotify
Apple podcast or wherever you get your
podcast so go check it out now I demand
it
your compliance is somewhat appreciated